and this one's a big one okay okay did
you love me hi I'm Paulo and I'm a
director here at Jubilee as you all know
we've been living in this global
pandemic and time of social isolation
and I've been sensing that people are
feeling lonely and longing for human
connection more people have been calling
their families and friends doing group
calls and it just made me realize that
this is a perfect opportunity for people
to reconnect and so we wanted to make a
series where we challenged people to
muster up the courage get out of the
comfort zones and call people they might
have had a falling-out with I am calling
an old friend well I'm calling my dad
and calling my ex-boyfriend I'm about to
call my dad
some reached out reconnected and took
the leap
when I was younger I actually moved to
Alaska when I got there I was a loner I
was the kid that no one really talked to
I was the loser but not Kim she
definitely was the one that spoke to me
she accepted me for who I was I want to
ask her if the reason why she stopped
talking to me it was because she had a
boyfriend I'm calling my dad I feel like
he neglected me as a daughter there were
so many lies there's so much mistrust I
really want to connect and understand if
he still sees me as his daughter or if
he's still willing to see me in the
future I guess you can see he was like
my first love you know the best somebody
you're always gonna have the most
feelings for the day that we kind of
just ended it was the day he told me
that he was signing another six-year
contract to go to Guam and he was like I
think we should just be friends and that
was like the last thing we said to each
other so I still want to express like
the fact that I'm still like in love
with him but it's also like we left off
like a weird spot my god has been in and
out of my life around sixth grade I
decided you know not to have anything I
didn't want to have anything to do with
him and you know he reached out to me
many times but I kept denying his effort
around this time last year I was in a
fatal car accident and during rehab I
was isolated most of the time so I had
OH
time and room for you know
self-reflection and improvement and
that's why I'm here today taking the
lead even last night knowing that I was
going to do this I couldn't sleep I just
I my mind is just racing it's going a
thousand miles an hour it's been a while
it's so good to see you thank you you
know working out little bit just a
little bit I was very scared I did
expect that he's going to give me an
apology hi papa
what happened okay so are you ready for
this I'm going to be asking you some
questions because I want to like it's
like a whole thing where you can like
reconnect with people and like you're
the person I want to reconnect with a
lot of these questions are gonna be like
about a relationship so yes get ready
yes okay I'm about to take a leap wish
me luck
okay again thank you for being here
do I have permission to report to report
this yes sir when I first moved to
Alaska you were one of my first friends
and you made me feel important you made
me feel loved
you made me feel welcomed and then there
was this period of time and still kind
of current where we just don't talk yeah
there wasn't right I started meeting
that's actually that's funny that you
say that because that's what I was gonna
ask you like why did that happen like
why did you I guess
cut off are not cut off our friendship
but why yeah I guess why did you cut it
off yeah it wasn't intentional I felt
like maybe it was me you know you got
like the the new shiny toy so you just
like sits guard me you know I like that
that's how I felt and you know I I just
for a long time I was hope that you know
this is like the start of something new
shut up High School Musical and I talk
to you later yes I will like I know we
haven't been talking for a while I just
wanted to know if you like still like
like want to see me again like in person
like you haven't seen her since yeah you
haven't seen us in a while like you
haven't seen you mm middle school I I
mean how come you haven't visited us why
you never asked
you're the one good you're the one who
told me face to face that I am no longer
your daughter and you tell that to
Caitlyn - and I don't understand why you
would say that and at the same time tell
me that you still love me like why would
you say that you love me if you don't
try to come see us and deny it right in
front of the court what did i do what
did I do to you have you thought about
how you respected us have you thought
about how many lies you said about my
mom have you thought of that where's the
respect than that how come you can't
respect your own daughters I'll catch
you later okay
do you believe like the question right
person wrong time
[Music]
this one's a big one okay okay did you
love me yes okay I was thinking like I
was thinking about it and I remember it
like the first time he said it your way
and you called me and you're like oh
gosh you were like I have something to
tell you he was like I hope you're
sitting down right now your member and
you're like I'm about to knock your
socks off and I was like why like what
are you gonna say to me right now and
you're like I love you and I was like
what was it hard to add in the
relationship
okay again thank you for being here the
last time we met
there were like 11 12 years of
resentment and you know things that were
unsaid well I was brutally honest and at
the same time I wasn't truthful and I
was having trouble you know facing the
things that I can and can't change in
one of those things is right you are my
dad
you know I same problems like with my
dad as well and trying to learn how to
love him and forgive him for not being a
part of my life so I get it and you a
lot like me and seeing how I honestly
feel so I did it I did this game on
yours to tell you that I
that I forgive you that I chose I choose
you and if you ever wondered that if I
ever ever loved you the
that I forgive you so I appreciate you
forgiving me that means the world to me
to hear you say that that was huge for
you huh yeah yeah I'm gonna meet once a
month you know you come here or I'll
come there
are we gonna talk the takes frequently
like I don't know I kind of need a
after-action plane seeing each other
once a month down really good again
thank you thank you thank you I'm gonna
I'm gonna end it now this this was a lot
for me in that moment in that moment was
you know just a lot and now I'm just you
know just letting just letting it go and
I feel lighter which you know I'm a
heavy individual but I feel lighter he
didn't answer my questions at all I'm
just going to be happy for it that's
that's it I'm happy for him
after everything there is so much
closure and I obviously if you need to
call someone right now and tell them hey
I love you hey I miss you take this as
an opportunity you never know unless you
try
I hope you enjoyed that episode I just
want to say thank you to all the people
who submitted videos were brave and
willing to be vulnerable on camera thank
you so much and if you're interested in
maybe reaching out or reconnecting with
someone and taking the leap then click
on the link in the description below I
maybe you can be featured in the future
episode thanks for watching and until
next time